What's it?
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
starting with
continuing in verse number four. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala commands the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam saying
stand in prayer
for the duration of the night
save a bit half or less. Thank you.
or add to half a little more than half
and recite the Quran.
He says,
"So this command of Allah
this is where the have the name of
the prophet Sam
used to refer to it as
the companions
would refer to
what is often referred to as
So it is
Allah commands him here in this verse
saying
is that a person recite the Quran
properly and intentionally.
that when a person is reciting the
Quran,
they are reciting each letter, each
verse
with intention
and they are reciting it melodously
and
with a kind of medium pacing as the
scholars tell us.
When the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam fulfilled this verse. The
companions learned his recitation.
His wives such as
was asked were asked about his
recitation. How did he recite?
And so she responded
[Silence]
Alim.
And so when she was asked about how he
recited the Quran, she said that he
would recite the Quran at a medium pace
and sometimes he would recite the Quran
at a very very slow pace
to the point that sometimes a shorter
chapter would seem longer than other
longer chapters.
because he was would recite it slowly
and the point of this recitation is that
the tongue not be ahead of the mind.
This is howb
defined it that the tongue not be ahead
of the mind. In order that the person's
understanding, the person's mind is able
to keep up with what the tongue is
reciting and is able to stop at each
letter at each word and understand that
letter and that word as they are
reciting.
The companions
home used to despise
reciting the Quran quickly, fast, in a
way that speeds past understanding and
that a person's understanding cannot
keep up with the Quran that they are
reciting.
was told once by one of his students
that he recited
of the Quran
meaning from
all the way to the end of the Quran and
he said
he said you've recited it in a fast pace
with the pace of the recitation of
poetry they used to recite poetry
quickly.
Why?
[Silence]
Ahmed,
right? in order to make it all rhyme and
make it all come together. That's how
they used to recite poetry. It is not
appropriate to recite the Quran like
this is what the companions are saying.
And so the companions
they would recite it slowly in a way
that the mind is not ahead of the
recitation.
And the scholars of recitation have
narrated to us four speeds of
recitation.
We have a which is the longest form and
that is used to teach. Right? Oftent
times you'll hear this or you'll see it
posted as
right they say
we've seen this before which is one
of those very very very long
recitations. This is actually not called
this is called this is called
is very slow and it's used to teach
right so that the student is able to
hear every single letter and where it's
coming from. This is not usually recited
in prayer. This is not recited when a
person is merely reciting and
unfortunately this recitation is one of
the most abused recitations.
In the last h 100red or so years with
the advent of the radio and the
recording the ability of recording sound
this kind of recitation was turned into
a kind of melodic almost musical
kind of thing where rules of recitation
are broken and it is used in order to
showcase the strength of the reciter.
And I will give you a a rule of thumb
right now.
When the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
was asked which recitation is the best
he said
the one whom he recites
you can feel his sincerity in his
recitation.
And a good litmus test of a good
recitation is when you're able to forget
the reciter.
So you're hearing the recitation, you're
not focused on the reciter. You're
focused on the words being recited. That
is a good reciter.
but a recer that stands in the way of
the Quran
and makes the recitation about him and
his abilities to recite and doing all
these things showing off with
regards to a person's breath and a
person's ability to change octaves and
all of these things. This is one of the
signs of the hour that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam warned us
about that the Quran would be turned
into a musical instrument used for
entertainment. Unfortunately,
the next which is referred to by the
scholars of recitation as toil and atil
is the best
speed of recitation if you will or mode
of recitation and that is that
is slow. not slow to where any rules of
recitation are broken, but not fast to
where any rules of recitation are
skipped over. And it is using what is
referred to as
means that all of the elongated vows are
fulfilled. This is referred to as tor.
Another is
a little bit faster than this. And the
fastest is al which is as fast as you
can go without jumbling any of the
letters.
Right? This is referred to as al and
this is usually used for revision,
usually used for things that. But
the companions
they understood that the point of
recitation is contemplating the Quran.
Right? And if that is the point of
recitation, then a person is to listen
to the Quran as he is recited. And when
a person is listening to a reciter, they
are not focused on the reciter. Rather,
they are focused on what is being
recited. Just a good what is a very
good? Someone who is not making the
about their abilities and their feet.
It's someone who makes you takes you to
a place of meditation and contemplation
and gets out of the way of the the
the information out of the way of the
the address and the connection
between the people and the Quran and the
people and the sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam.
Who said
[Silence]
he said,
"Do not recite the Quran the way that
the way that poetry is recited.
Rather
be patient in its recitation
and pause at its awesome places and
places of of of intrigue
and recite the Quran to move people's
hearts. And when you are reciting, do
not make your focus the end of the
chapter. Don't be focused on the end of
the chapter. be focused on the exact
word and letter that is being recited at
the moment and this is how it should be
recited in the in the salah. This is how
it should be recited
outside of salah in one of these
three modes that we mentioned. the
Quran
of course is a powerful book and its
recitation is unlike any other thing
there. It has its own language, its own
spelling, its own way of writing, its
own script, right? The way that the
letters are written, this is different
than any other thing. , and it has its
own way of reciting, being recited, its
own recitation.
And that recitation is transmitted along
with its wording. So where do we get the
recitations of the Quran? We get it
through chains of narration.
We do not get it through what sounds
good.
And this is where a lot of this
the mat come from which the
scholars of Islam have judged as being
innovative and innovation in Islam. What
are the mat? The mats are musical
chords, octaves, literally musical
chords that were that were set up using
either a piano or an acoustic in order
to harmonize the recitation of the Quran
with the various musical chords and the
various octaves. This is what it is. And
so when you learn it, you're learning
what was set up by people who used a
guitar or used a piano or used any of
these different instruments in order to
set these seven or five or six
recitations up. And they call these
these were never learned by the
companions
nor the nor
this is something that is been
introduced way later and unfortunately
it has made its way into some
universities. It's even sometimes taught
as if you know books have been
written on it and so forth. However, the
scholarship of Islam have rejected that
there be any
kinship between the Quran's
recitation
and musical theory that there be no
kinship between musical theory and the
recitation of the Quran. And some
scholars have even gone to the point of
considering this musical
spin on the recitation of the Quran
as being almost a mockery of the Quran.
Im Ahmed was asked about this, asked
about reciting the Quran in this way and
he said and the person asking him his
his name was you know Mustafa or
whatever it was Muhammad or Abdullah and
he said would you be okay with somebody
saying your name yeah Abdullah
right you would think this person is
making fun of you it is not appropriate
to elongate those letters in that way.
So what sounds very good in a song does
not sound good in the Quran. It is not
appropriate. And what's interesting is
that
probably about 40 or 50 years ago, there
was this kind of movement and it kind of
blew up a little bit more with the
internet. And that is that they were
getting famous Arabic singers, right, to
recite verses or chapters of the Quran
because that's that's the way that our
religion has be been abused by people,
right? If you're a singer, then of
course you can recite the Quran, right?
Because you're a singer, that means
you're very very skilled. in the Quran,
you know, that's small potatoes for for
these guys. This is the idea. And so
they would have these singers come and
recite these chapters of the Quran
in the way that they would sing their
ballads. And this here is absolutely
atrocious. No Muslim should ever accept
such a thing be done with his book.
Men have bled for this book. Continue to
bleed for this book. We have a river of
blood and sweat and tears
going back 1,500 years for this book.
For some singer to come and pick it up
and show us how it's done. This is not
appropriate, not acceptable. And we will
never accept somebody to come and meddle
with our book in that way. Singing,
music, entertainment, art, keep that
away from something that is this.
This is the book of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. It is the final book of Allah to
be revealed to humanity. It is not to be
used and abused in that way.
collected a narration in his book
and a narration in which
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
he said hasten to do good deeds before
one of six things rears its head in
society. He said,
"The leadership of the foolish and inept
and that governments will become bloated
and have a lot of policing and a lot of
military that will force citizens into
adhering to the government's every
whim and will.
And judgment will be something that
is for sale for the highest bidder
and kin and kith will be broken and
family structures will be divided.
people will not keep familial ties
any longer
and blood human blood will be very cheap
be something that people won't think
twice about spilling
[Silence]
He said, "And groups of Muslims that
will turn the Quran into a musical
instrument. They will put a man to lead
them in prayer not because he is the
most knowledgeable amongst them nor
because he is most understanding amongst
them. They will place him to lead them
in prayer so that he will sing to them
during their prayer.
Subhanal.
[Silence]
I know what